المشاهدين الذي يظهر على شاشاتنا في هذه
الاثناء مراسل الجزيره نقلا عن مصادر
محليه يقول ان هناك ذوي انفجار ضخم لوسط
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا ذوي انفجار
ضخم وسط العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مباشره
الى ام درمان حيث ينضم الينا من هناك
مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت هيثم هل من
تفاصيل عن او اي معلومات رشحت عن هذا
الانفجار الضخم الذي تتحدثون عنه
انعم ما قبل هذا الانفجار يعني هنا في ام
درمان ومنذ اكثر من ساعه تدور اشتباكات
عنيفه جدا في منطقه ام درمان تحديدا في
الاجزاء الغربيه من حي المهندسين كنا نسمع
اصوات اشتباكات قويه جدا استمرت لاكثر من
ساعه وما تزال مستمره حتى الان وهذه
الاشتباكات يعني بدات منذ عصر اليوم وايضا
كانت هناك اشتباكات صبغت هذه الاشتباكات
في منطقه
الشرق النيل كان هناك قصف من الطيران
التابع للجيش على مواقع للدعم قوات الدعم
السريع وايضا في منطقه شارع الستين بوسط
الخرطوم وكذلك في منطقه بحري هذه
المواجهات وهذا التصعيد الذي ياتي في هذه
الفتره المسائيه من هذا اليوم بعد ان كانت
هناك حاله من الهدوء تسود مناطق الخرطوم
الثلاثه طيله الصباح اليوم ونهار اليوم
ولكن في هذه الساعات المسائيه ازدادت
وتيره هذه الاشتباكات او اندلعت بشكل
مفاجئ ويبدو ان هناك يعني اشتباكات قويه
ما تزال تدور في اكثر الموقع ايضا نرى
تصاعد دخان ولكن تفاصيل هذا الانفجار حتى
الان لم تتكشف ولكن هناك اعمده دخان
تتصاعد من مواقع مختلفه من العاصمه طبعا
ياتي ذلك بعد يوم من توقيع الاطراف على
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار قصير الامد ولكن
هذا الاتفاق طبعا سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد
48 ساعه اي
غدا الاثنين في تمام الساعه 9:45 مساء
وهذه الفتره التي حددت هي لكي تقوم
الاطراف بايصال الشرح هذا الاتفاق لقواتها
على الارض وكذلك
لحسهم على الامتثال لهذا الاتفاق ولكن قبل
بدايه هذا التنفيذ نرى الان هذه
الاشتباكات المستمره ونسمع دويا
الانفجارات القويه الذي يتواصل من الاطراف
المتسارعه ورغم ان هناك ترحيب كبير من
جهاد عديده لهذه لهذه الاتفاقيه لوقف
اطلاق النار سواء كانت من الاحزاب
السياسيه او من قبل الكيانات المهنيه
المختلفه وحتى من المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي الذي ابدا ترحيبا كبيرا بهذا
الاتفاق وعده خطوه مهمه في بدايه لوقف
اطلاق النار يمكن ان يطور الى وقف شامل
لاطلاق النار مستقبلا مع ان تلك الطرفين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بدايه التزامهما
مبدئيا بهذا الاتفاق ان نسمع هذه الاصوات
التي تنطلق من وقت لاخر وما زالت مستمره
لاطلاق النار ويبدو ان شراسه القتال تدور
الان حاليا في اندرون وايضا في اكثر من
موقع شكرا جزيلا لك من اندرمان مراسلنا
هيثم